I'm not gonna bother with the first two
I'm okay with those five and negative
two you happy yes look okay to me find X
if now this one's slightly trickier you
don't just put a number in if f of X
equals seven then that's this thing on
the left hand side you see that so
that's why I Brian right that's why
Brian wrote two X minus one that's f of
X is seven and then off he goes who
solves okay now these two here asked me
a question before which is a good
question for all of us
why did i suddenly change the wedding of
the question why didn't I just say as I
did earlier evaluate any suggestions why
I didn't use that word it has to do with
the word itself or E what do you think
yeah so evaluate has to do the final
answer because the word itself says what
it's doing tell me the value so a value
something like eleven or five right this
is not a value it's not a value it's got
its got variables it approaches it's an
expression right two x plus one six
eight minus one are you happy with those
thumbs up okay well done now here's what
I want you to do in DES boss so I'm
gonna move this for a second
look at okay you can see it so what have
we created two X minus one you tell me
have a look at it what kind of object is
this it's a straight line what can you
tell me about that straight line there
are two things number one it's uh I
suppose you can talk about the x
intercept but a more obvious thing is
though is the y intercept which is
Maegan one there it is right there
and then what does that to do what's
that about it's great and so you see
it's quite steep in fact if you look at
a point like say here right if you go
across one unit sure enough you got two
that's what the gradient to means all
good okay now what I want to have a look
at is this one down here seen this one
we put in X plus one every one sided
then we got this so I want you to also
write down or type rather this guy here
if I go F
of X plus 1 okay now I haven't evaluated
it but I want you to actually see what
is going on
do I need to close the blinds do I
really come on guys they get to watch it
but I want you to focus I want you to
focus okay now I want you to look at the
red blue lines look carefully and tell
me what is going on do you remember what
we were doing inverse functions the
other day right well we're doing inverse
functions we said oh it's about a
reflection do you remember that
what kind of reflection was it it's a
very specific kind of you had to turn
your head do you remember it was out it
was yeah sort of 45 degrees right so if
I gave you a function like say the
exponential right I had to put an extra
light in here to reflect across which
line was it wipers X nailed it okay so
there's no y equals x like now do you do
the turn right put your head over and
then I'll know you're ready other way
around all the way you do your
reflection across there do you see the
symmetry you see it right there it is
okay so there was a geometric meaning to
the inverse and there's a geometric
meaning to this tell me how do I get
from the red line watch carefully watch
my head watch my hand watch my head how
do I get from the red line to the blue
line
what is changed I've I've slid I've
moved I've shifted or translated now
this is a bit tricky I've actually moved
a couple of different ways and I'll show
you an example this that makes a bit
more obvious you can either say I've
moved two units upwards do you see that
every point here you can point to a spot
two units above and there you are on the
blue line or alternatively instead of up
and down you can think about left and
right how far have I moved left and
right and which way left all right
look carefully let me zoom in a little
bit closer for you
here you see how far am i moved I've
moved one unit see how this is uh this
is plus 1/2 this is negative 1/2 is that
ok so from here to here one unit are you
okay with me honestly are you just
messing with me okay all right so think
about this with me I'll give you another
example and you can put this in fact or
you can do this the same thing with me
right see that 2x minus 1 I want you to
change it I will show you exactly how I
want you to take away the 2 like that
just stop in it and then next to the X I
want you to down the bottom if you see
next to X&Y there's a button that says
a-square do you see that button go ahead
and click it for me ok so now what have
we done we're still exploring this same
idea we're still going to function and
then we've got an f of X plus 1 that
we're putting into it ok notice the
order we started with red and then we go
to blue I'm gonna ask you again how do I
get from the red graph which is what
kind of shape you're in
what is this it's a parabola how do I
get from the red parabola preserve there
from the red parabola to the blue one
what's the change I've translated now
you can see them more clearly country
I've got one unit to the left see these
ones one who's gone to zero negative one
has gone to negative two you see it now
yes ok so tell me what you think that
means all right so you can see what are
we playing around here with and the
great thing about this is you don't need
me to help you now you can fiddle with
this yourself ok put any function you
like in there ok in fact I'm gonna ask
you what function would you like me to
put Oh cute there you go okay you can
put any function you like in there and
if what you do is say alright let's
change the function let's put X plus 1
in there instead of X's right then what
happens is you move one unit to the left
does that make sense ok now please note
this please notice and this is a really
important point so just
look up from your laptops for a second
because it is every time we teach a
topic we know that there's particular
errors that students always make all the
time okay so I want to point this out to
you a lot of trick question on the
Cartesian plane when you see plus one
what direction does that usually send
you now I'll give you different answers
because it depends on what kind of plus
one it is right so for example if I said
to you here's a coordinate one one and I
said add one to that well then you'd go
over two to one where you'd go to the
right okay
but this plus one is sending you any
other direction do you see that it's
gone to the left which is the reverse of
this thing so now if you take your f of
X plus one and if you delete it or this
delete the plus one right I'm looking at
I yet I want you to make a prediction
first if I want to put in something like
say X minus three
what would you predict happens let's see
if you're right there it is so you can
see the original which was in red and
the new version which is in blue it's
been translated in the right direction
okay are you with me you're following
okay now I'll lead you to have a think
about what if you change not just the
plus or minus well if you change number
at the front hmm it's a class it's a
class okay have a look you can do with
me
that's the greatest thing about this
about desmos you can just play okay you
know what happens if I go X plus
whatever X minus whatever what do you
predict will happen if I go say to X
have a think about it hmm
let's find out if I put in I - what's it
done
it's gone steeper did you notice that
let me change the original function
let's make it something like that okay
sir look same version but steeper right
or another way you could say it is I
don't really want to close the blinds
but you guys could concentrate right you
can yeah I'm actually going to suggest
that making a steeper as a vertical
thing right but a better way to think
about it is about horizontally can you
see why what number are we changing what
number are we mucking around with now
look carefully look carefully it's the X
right that's why when you did this it
moved one unit to there which way left
because it's left and right X's are
about the horizontal right so they move
left and right when I put this two in
here again it's doing something to the
horizontal it's it's squashing it right
it's compressing it so for example I
change the 2x into let's go divided by
three what do you predict will happen
it'll become why don't you see it right
so you're gonna have a play with this
and you can experiment